well as many of you know our Anthony
Mason has been pulling double-duty these
last few weeks last month he was named
co-anchor of CBS this morning along with
Gayle King and Tony to copal all while
still joining us and all of you right
here on Saturdays but today is Anthony's
last Saturday with us after anchoring
this broadcast for the last seven years
they say all good things must come to an
end no they do and as you'll see right
now Anthony has brought a lot of good
things to CBS this morning Saturday and
welcome to the weekend everyone I'm
Anthony Mason
[Music]
breaking overnight another election
hacking scandal why risk a trade war at
this point it's a good question breaking
news overnight of several large
wildfires burning across the west where
do we think the situation with North
Korea really is at this point court
papers filed on two key Trump campaign
aides hi Anthony it's Vinita it was such
an honor to sit next to you for three
years welcome to CBS this morning
Saturday Anthony there are a few people
in this world who I would look forward
to waking up in the middle of the night
to spend time with
[Music]
this is really good hardware so nice
that's sort of drinking this in the
break cheers with our coffee this is our
cake on an old-fashioned you know how to
get into our harvest over here because
I'm thinking you know and my beverage
has a clothespin in it yeah and it can't
beat the beverages
[Music]
do you feel like you've been kicked out
of the family I do
[Music]
you're 67 now yeah I'm about to be sixty
yeah did I read you a black hole son in
15 minutes the initial idea was in a car
ride I was just driving home from the
studio late at night if we were weird
vampires come from well now that's not a
question for me that's the question is
the oldest time we strapped right across
the face like this is like a raccoon I
look like a zombie
[Laughter]
I think you're one of the few people
who's been able to do business and music
and make it all work we spend so much
time listening to you talk about
musicians and how talented they are and
people don't realize how truly gifted
you are at your craft we always had so
much fun have a great weekend everybody
too and I will always look up to you for
your interest in so many different
things from culture to music you always
bring it so I think well wishes but also
well done we called Anthony Mason style
oh my god Anthony cheers boo
[Music]
on CBS this morning Saturday
and there is no better thing we can say
than with your favorite a little bourbon
we would not be where we are without you
my friend I think you would but I wanted
to say thank you to well to everybody in
epic a Jarvis is the one who convinced
me to take this job very reluctantly at
the beginning and I'm grateful to heard
of the Vinita and Iyer Alex Wagner my
other coast and these two who know I
love them very much she loves us very
much everybody behind the scenes Greg
Moore by the way the producer behind
some of that their folks like Greg and
and Marci Waldman who does the dish have
been here my whole time and they've done
this show is put together by a very
small staff with a very big heart an
extraordinary amount of love I want to
thank all of them and our extraordinary
executive producer Bryan Applegate who
is the one who fine-tunes every detail
on the show and has taken it over these
seven years and made it what it is today
a lot of people have sent me a note
saying I'm worried about Saturday
sessions don't don't worry it's not
going away and I'm coming back to do
some more of those interviews so and
plus you get Jeff Glor so you like that
it's like an extra bonus I have to get
used to Tony getting in his ear Tony as
that producer also who's been working
with you on this show probably Jeff's
gonna have to learn how to bring them
coffee because that's what I do and
they're gonna get very grumpy thank you
to everybody out there who's joined us
over the years it's meant the world to
me that you appreciate what what all the
folks here do they put a lot into it and
we get up early on Saturday and here's
to you Anthony thank you thank you I'll
be watching next seven watch up anyway I
know you would Jeff I'm sorry about us
but you're just gonna have to deal now
deal with a lots of you have a great
weekend enjoy cheers to all of you